it's not hard to understand the fear of
being alone the empty apartment after
work the eeriness of Sunday afternoons
the sense of exclusion during the
holidays we know the Agony's of being on
our own very well what's far less well
understood is the enormous Lehigh price
exact 'add on the other side of the
equation the fear of being alone is
perhaps responsible for more unhappy
relationships more throttling of
psychological development and more pent
up misery than almost any other it is by
any reckoning one of the single greatest
contributors to human misery and the
driver of some of our weightiest and
most unfortunate decisions if only we
were able to get the costs of what is
for the most part a simple
misapprehension clear in our minds we
might save ourselves a substantial
portion of our lives we can pick out at
least seven unnecessary penalties for a
start and most obviously people who are
afraid of being alone makes some very
wrong choices around the company that
they keep they have no option but to
privilege anyone over the appropriate
one they don't have the strength to be
able to hold out as one must for the
20th or 200th candidate the only souls
with any realistic chance of ending up
with a partner they deserve are those
who've properly reconciled themselves to
the prospect of perhaps never being with
anyone at all being with not quite the
right person sounds almost bearable but
extended over time like a proverbial
pebble in a shoe slightly wrong ends up
indistinguishable from entirely horrific
every beautiful location we travel to
together will be ruined
every promising moment will be trampled
upon every success will be compromised
what may begin a slight fractious Nisour
tedium winds up as cataclysmic
irritation self disgust
actual misery broken finances and the
kind of excruciating loneliness that
ironically merely and innocently being
on our own would never have the power to
generate furthermore when terrified of
loneliness we have no strength to argue
for our needs within any relationship
one is always at the mercy of the one
who fears loneliness less partners
develop an advanced sense of the person
who has nowhere else to go
it's no use stamping our feet after an
argument and saying I've had enough when
in reality everyone knows that we will
never have had enough so scared a week
of having dinner on our own we can't now
imagine ever knowing how to change the
dishwasher fluid alone walking into a
party by ourselves or taking the
initiative to send our nephews birthday
presents so used to have we become to
using the other person to compensate for
our weaknesses we experience none of the
bracing but also educative pressures
visited upon the single who have no
choice but to overcome their inhibitions
those brave souls who have to learn how
to garden go on holidays in the
mountains endure empty weekends call up
their mother or cook a chicken and
thereby achieve the resilient competence
upon which true social discrimination
and liberty rest for those who have to
lightly signed away their freedoms there
are sure to be constant and searing
reminders of what they foregone every
party and every walk down a busy street
will provide evidence of what might have
been all those potentially fascinating
charming members of humanity they have
now forever been disbarred from getting
to know because they were so unnaturally
scared of having a bed to themselves for
a few more years
it isn't just other people we won't get
to know it's also ourselves the constant
presence of companions stops us from
making friends with our own minds and
exploring our feelings and ideas in a
way that only extended stretches of
solitude allow we use another person to
distract us
whenever any slightly painful or
challenging internal matter comes into
view that ends up being so much we won't
ever really feel or understand about
ourselves so many big questions about
our careers and our ultimate purpose
that we will ignore because there was
always someone else on hand to chat to
about what to order in for dinner worst
of all we might not even be actively
miserable after a while we'll grow used
to cozy mediocrity we won't be curious
or Restless we won't dare as the single
must to go up to strangers and risk our
pride we'll stop learning will believe
that we've answered our needs completely
but only on the basis of suppressing our
knowledge of what our needs really are
to start to correct everything that
stems from this ridiculous fear of being
alone
we should from a young age learn that
being alone never means there is
something wrong with us just that we are
being appropriately patient until what
truly satisfies us shows up if indeed it
ever danced we have a choice we have not
been punished
we will never learn the true promise of
community discover our own interests or
hold out for the connections we deserve
until we make a genuine peace with the
prospect of a life by ourselves
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life such
as finding a good enough partner and
mastering the art of confidence click
now to learn more